so did you know each other prior to
filming and what surprised you most
about sure iOS's of him all on my walls
you know he was like he was like a guy
pushing my loving this club pretty
obvious Edgar Ramirez and usher our
total pals in real life but in their new
boxing drama hands of stone they play
rivals Roberto Duran and Sugar Ray
Leonard I'm gonna knock you out
haters are losers and I don't like you I
have to know as training athletes for
this film did you ever feel like my
goodness am I gonna reach a breaking
point I mean you're training for what
five six hours a day the things that all
of that struggle that we both went
through informed the movie and the
characters you cannot understand the
state of mind of a boxer if you don't
come as close as possible to the
deprived into the pressure remember the
dinner we had yeah we had sushi and
everybody was having rice and for the
delicious things and we only had a
little salmon uh torture for him because
he because he couldn't eat Eggar man he
had to go up and down and it was I know
it was a lot for you man and just like
Sugar Ray had Juanita wilkinson uh sure
has Grace Miguel his manager and wife of
nearly a year I'm just really happy to
have found an incredible made a partner
who understands you know my growth and I
understand hers as a father what brings
you the most joy what are you most proud
of the both boys I think I'm a little
bit heavy on myself because I have to
work but what was beautiful is my oldest
son uh sure
his birthday happened while we were
filming so I brought him over he had a
bowling party for me
Navid he is definitely gonna be an act
okay yeah he's super dramatic but uh uh
sure
more than athlete he spent this summer
at Jordans camp he put him on the spot
and he missed his shot like I was so
embarrassed came off
I missed it I was like you got to go
back in man this is about how you get up